ありがとうございます皆さん改めまして
こんにちは
ありがとうございますGPSランナーの
清水直樹と申しますランニングアプリの
GPS機能を使って地球上に
絵やメッセージを描くランニング
アーティストをしています
一体何なのか作品を見てもらうのが一番
早いと思います
これら全て走って
描いた奇跡です
ありがとうございますありがとうござい
ます
私はですねランフォースマイルという新年
のもと見た人が
ちょっぴり笑顔に幸せになれるそんな作品
作りをし続けています
そんな中で今まで世界10カ国でこれを
作ってきました
約1100作品一つ一つの作品の
平均の距離だいたい9キロから10km
皇居の周りをぐるぐる2周分ぐらいです
7年半この作業ひたすら走り続けてきて
その総距離1万キロに達しました
ありがとうございます
とはいえ1万キロちょっとわかりにくい
ですよね
図式化しました
こんな感じです
今皆さんがいる京都を出発すると直線距離
でなんとスペインバルセロナまで行けて
しまうそんな距離私は
走って描き続けてきました
どうしてそんなことをしているのかなぜ
走り続けて描き続けているのか
理由があります
ズバリ
スポーツを競うものからよりたくさんの
方々が楽しめるように
競わないものにその裾野を広めるためです
私はこの自身の活動を
競わないランニング文化を作るという風に
表現しています
目標1位になることではありません
最後まで楽しく
描ききることがゴールです
むしろ歩いてもOK
休憩もし放題そんなスポーツなんです
ちっちゃい子供でもおじいちゃんおばあ
ちゃんでも
障害を持っていても国債国を超えてでも
みんなが一緒にできてしまう地球を
キャンバスにしたスポーツGPSアート
今日はそれを皆さんに知っていただくため
にこちらでお話をさせていただきます
せっかくこうやってこの会場で会えたのを
皆さんご縁です
体験をしてほしいということでクイズ1問
用意してきました今からある地図が出ます
注意してご覧ください
こちら
フランスのベルサイユ宮殿の中庭の地図
ですこの中に世界的に有名なあるものが
隠れています
ちょっとわかりにくいヒント出します
航空写真
いかがでしょうか
きっと数名にはもう見えてると私には思い
ます正解はこちらです赤い線で弾きました
横たわっているのでちょっと立てますね
はい
こちら実はフランスのベルサイユ宮殿の
中庭にあの世界的な
著名なネズミさんが隠れていました
私はこれを描くためだけにフランスに行っ
てきました
思う存分笑ってやってくださいありがとう
ございます
このように地図の中から絵を見つけて実際
に
走って描くこれが私の仕事です
どうしてこんなことをそもそもするように
なったのかそのきっかけ
実は私GPSランナーやる前前職小学校の
教師をやっていました
この体験が大きなきっかけとなりました
8年間教師やっていましたそのうち2年間
車椅子の
体が不自由な児童の
担任の先生をつきっきりでしていました
そんな彼と接するうちにたくさんのこと
学ばせてもらいまし
た特に運動スポーツその概念をたくさん彼
にひっくり返して勉強させてもらいまし
た体が不自由な人運動が苦手な人たくさん
いますその人たちが
めちゃくちゃ楽しいって思える
エンターテイメントとしてのスポーツ
競争しない
そんな
素敵な
文化を作ることはできないかそう考える
ようになったんです
そんなことを考えながら私はある年の冬
ですね福男に並んでいました
あの開門と同時にみんながザーッとレース
をする皆さんもしかしたらテレビで見た
ことある方きっとたくさんいらっしゃい
ますよね
頷いていただいてありがとうございます
あの服男ですが私の地元兵庫県の西宮市に
ある
戎神社というところで毎年開催されてい
ます私も
並んでいましたそして最短距離走りたい
なって思ってこの地図を見ていたんです
神社の地図ですすると最短距離じゃない
ものが見えてしまいまし
たネズミじゃないですよ
西
という感じがファッと見えてきたんですね
その瞬間はっと思ったんですこれ走るため
いやむしろ歩いてもいいな
競わなくていいしかもスマホを正々堂々
運動のために使えるのでこれ子どもたちが
ニヤニヤしながらやりそうだなって思った
んです
これは
素晴らしいスポーツになるんじゃないかと
思った瞬間でしたものは試しまずは走って
みようということで西宮ラブ
私が1100作品で初めて
走った作品です
めちゃくちゃ楽しかったんですね色んな
景色を見ることができました自分の知ら
なかった場所も
これにはまっていろんなところで描くよう
になりましたそしてついに日本飛び出して
しまいました
初めて行ったのが台湾
皆さんも言ったことある人多いかもしれ
ませんねなぜ台湾に行ったのかれんしと
いうあまり聞き慣れない東海岸である都市
で実は大震災が起きたんですその加連市に
私は
応援に行きたいと思って応援メッセージを
走って
描きに行ってきましたただすぐ戻ってき
ました子供たちの授業があったので怒ら
れるので
そうすると事件は
現場で起こってたんです
大ニュースです
国営放送をはじめ台湾全土で1週間私の
ニュースが流れ始めると
異常事態になっていました
スマホは取材のため授業をやってんのに
なるんですねもう子供たちごめんって言い
ながら
過ごしていました自身のSNSにも
たくさんも数え切れないぐらいの
ありがとうの嵐
結構読めなかったんですけれども気持ち
たくさん伝わってきました
こんな経験をするうちに私は思うように
なったんですねこれただのスポーツじゃ
ないぞ
たくさんのその障害を持ってる子であっ
たりとか体が不自由な人のためのスポーツ
だけじゃなくて国と国の
友情をつなぐようなスポーツにもできる
可能性がめちゃくちゃあるっていう風に
感じたんです
これをもし叶えることができたら教師を
やるより今教えてる子どもたちそして
未来の世界の子どもたちに残せるものが
大きいというふうに思ったんです
気づけば私は
退職届を迷わず出していました
きっと6年生の担任をやっていたことも
あります彼らを卒業させて自分も
ちょうどいいタイミングで
卒業そしてGPSランナー商標登録そして
おそらく世界で一人プロとしてこの道一本
で食べていこうという決心でこの職業を
作りました
そして様々なイベントをしていくことに
なりますなぜかというと走ってるだけでは
もちろんご飯食べていけないという覚悟は
あったのでこれ皆さんがよく心配される私
の
収入のところでもあるのでバッチリ聞いて
ください
これが一番基本なところですマップ作り
体験をしていますこれは何かというとご
当地のマップを用意しますそこにお絵かき
をするように
オリジナルのルートを考えるんですまさに
お絵かきです
楽しいんですそしてそれせっかく作ったの
で行こうぜということで
ウォーキング歩いたりランニング
走ったりするイベントも開催しています多
世代参加型
健康に良いだけじゃなくて交流も生まれて
さらに観光までできてしまうそんな
イベントです
そして次一番人気
ゴミ拾いですゴミ拾いをした奇跡がなんと
地上絵になる
そんなイベントをしています今自治体
企業そして商店街などタイアップして
日本全国でこの活動地球をピカピカに
しようぜっていう活動をさせてもらって
ます
ただここに来たのがコロナです
皆さんもきっといろんなイベント中止に
なった行きたかったのにそんな思いした
ことたくさんあったと思います私も同じ
思いでした集まりたくても集まれない
そんな中で生み出して新しい企画がこちら
のオンラインコンテストでし
た自分たち
描いた作品をオンラインに投稿するそこで
交流を生み出す
さらにそこに消費も生み出したかったので
私はいろんな景品ご当地のグルメであっ
たりとかスポーツ用品であったりとか
いろんなところに声をかけて一緒にこの
取り組みを広げていきましたその結果
日本中でマラソン大会が中心になりました
しかしオンラインマラソン大会は行われた
んですそのコンテンツのメインの一つとし
ていろんなところでこの
オンラインコンテンツトっていうのを使っ
てもらうようになりました
これらの経験をいろんなところで還元し
たいと思って講演会もさせていただいてい
ます子供たちとやるときは工程で一緒に
描いたり楽しみながら体を動かしながら
やっています
さらに私はずっと未来を見ていろんなこと
を考えています2つだけ皆さんに紹介させ
ていただきたいです
1つ目
このアイデアを高齢者を支えるアイデアに
したいということですマップを作ることは
脳のいいトレーニング素敵なトレーニング
にもなる
さらに作ったものをみんなで描きに行く
これは健康にもなるし人のつながりを作る
ためにもなるさらに
生きがいの喪失にもなります
この活動をどんどんどんどん日本から世界
へ広げていきたいというふうに考えてい
ます
もう一つ
世界中の人の心を一つにしたアートを作り
たい
1人1文字
もしくは
各国1文字連結アートつなげると一つの
作品ができるんですコロナでなかなか海外
に行けない今だからこそこのようなアート
を作りたいというふうに思っています
ちなみにこれ120人で作った後です
世界中の言葉でサンキューシェイシェイ
オブリガードありがとうという言葉を
去年ですね2021年3月11日
東日本大震災から10年の節目に世界に
向けてありがとうっていうアートを
つくろうと呼びかけたらこれだけの人が
集まって協力してくれました
このような作品を世界中の人と一緒に作り
たい私の夢の一つです
このように私は
いろんなところを走り回りながらスポーツ
とアートを融合させたらどんな素敵なこと
ができるんだろう世の中のためにずっと
考えながら開拓をしてきました
ただやっぱり
教師公務員先生やめてGPSランナーと
いうわけのわからない仕事をやるこれは
とんでもない労力のいることでしたもう
無謀でした
例えるのであれば何かちっちゃい手作りの
ボートで
めちゃくちゃ広い海を一人で結構行く感じ
ですいつ転覆するかわからないいつ食料が
なくなって死んでしまうかわからないもう
そんな状況で今も走り続けています
辛かったことがあります
始めた当初です一番言われたこと
何で教師やめるのもったいない公務員安定
しているのにそんなことを言われました
さらには
教師やりながらやったらいいじゃん趣味で
いいじゃないか
であったりとか収入無理でしょうそんな
ことはもうめちゃくちゃ言われました
本当につらかったなぜかというと幸せに
なってほしいと思ってた人たちから私は
反対に自分のチャレンジをして笑われてき
たんです
そこに追い打ちがかけられましたコロナ
です
イベントができなくなったさらにそこで私
はアルバイトを実は掛け持ちしていました
ただ飲食店
休業です
収入立たれましたそしてついに限界が来
ました小学校の教師の時に一生懸命この
冒険のために貯めたお金なくなりました月
でしまったんです
危うく家がなくなりかけたこともあります
それぐらい追い詰められました
そんな中では私はどうしてもこの活動
を続けたかったんです
私にできる表現は一つでし
た助けて
この一言を世の中に知ってもらうことでし
たただ私の新年一番最初に言いました
ランフォースマイルです
僕私の猫の作品を作るところには絶対に
笑顔がないといけないという信念があり
ますなのでこの辛いみんな助けてっていう
思いの一部にこんな最後言葉を混ぜました
清水お肉好きです
SOS今日最も大事ですこれだけ覚えて
帰ってください
私は肉が大好きです今夜皆さん食べ
ましょう
こんなこともありですね実はこの数日後
私の家のレート投稿ありとあらゆる肉で
埋め尽くされました
野菜やお米たくさんたくさん届きました
全国で出会った方々からでした感謝の言葉
しかありませんちなみにこの会場にも今
たくさん実は来てくれてるんですこの場を
借りて改めてお礼申し上げます
人と人のこのつながりというのは本当に
宝物だな心から思った瞬間でし
た競わないランニング文化を作るこれは私
の人生をかけたミッションですそこにある
のは
人々の健康
幸せそれから国と国をつなぐ友情です
教師を辞めてでも
成し遂げたい夢が私にはあります
ただ一人の力ではできないこれはもう
むちゃくちゃ三好みで身にしみて感じてい
ます
この素敵な舞台
ここを新しいスタートラインに世界中の人
と手を取り合ってこの
活動をゆっくりゆっくり前前進めていき
たいというふうに思っていますともに素敵
な社会を皆さんと一緒に作っていけたらと
いうふうに思っています
最後にこの
テレックスという素敵な
舞台作ってくれた学生スタッフの皆さん
先生方そして今日ここに聞きに来てくれて
いる皆さん
最大の感謝の気持ちを込めて
京都からこの作品を送って終わりの言葉に
変えさせていただきますご清聴いただき
ありがとうございました
[拍手]